that's
and he talks too much that's why i like
you you don't talk you just listen it's
good
and the captain has turned on the fasten
seat belt sign a little turbulence
coming up should be no problem just
remain in your seat until the sign is
turned off thank you for your
cooperation
okay
excuse me for the bathroom
hi excuse me yeah yeah
i need you to take your seat the fasten
seatbelt sign is on yeah i'm just gonna
go to the bathroom for a second i'll be
right back
okay i understand what you want to do uh
unfortunately i'm gonna need you to
observe the and seat belt cyan that'd be
much appreciated
right just i read on the internet that
it's not against the law for me to go to
the bathroom while the fasten seat belt
sign is on
so see what side it's not but is it
against the law though
the light is on is it against the law
you see that there's a picture of a seat
belt on that sign no but is it against
the law
though the fascinating seatbelt in the
thought but is it against certain
signs what is it against the seatbelt
sign is on but is it against evil sign
but is it against the law it's on
seatbelts
difficult you're being very different
law law not illegal not illegal
not illegal okay legal fascinating
illegal fasten yourself
[Music]
legal sir i have to piss and i have to
get in the toilet can you lower your
voice
i have to piss i have to okay lower your
intensity you're louder than me
you're yelling you're in my face you're
the one who i think needs to tone it
down right now
you are screaming at me you're hurting
my eardrums
that wasn't a word you're not saying a
word this is a word
that's not that's not a word that's a
tongue trick
okay sir sir sir if you would like
i would not like to i would not like to
sit down
what i'd like to do is go take the
bathroom
because it's not against
the law so i'm gonna go to the bathroom
okay mark
with a k
oh
so
[Music]
you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
and your captain has turned off the
fasten seatbelt sign feel free to move
around the cabin
thank you for your cooperation
you